guerilla theories used to work as a
welder four years ago he says these days
he cannot find work and needs to collect
cardboard for recycling to make a living
I used to have a job and now I'm on the
street because it's the only thing I can
find I have three children and it's a
challenge to support my family I believe
the government of mauricio macri for
everything that is going wrong on Monday
official statistics revealed poverty
rates have gone up by almost 8 percent
this past year the devaluation of the
peso currency which began in 2018 has
led to an over 50 percent inflation rate
pushing more families below the poverty
line and it's all happening in the
lead-up to the presidential elections in
October the presidential campaign has
officially started in Argentina in the
middle of a deep economic crisis that
has heard Mauricio macri's chances of
being reelected opposition candidate
Alberto Fernandez says that macri's
market-friendly reforms have damaged
Argentina's economy and has deteriorated
the living conditions of millions of
people around the country Fernandez
whose running mate is former President
Cristina Fernandez de Kirchner defeated
Macri in an August primary vote by a
wide margin mr. president don't come and
tell us now that it's time to work when
you've destroyed millions of jobs in the
country and don't tell us you will now
fight poverty because you've already
forced at least 5 million people in the
country into poverty Macri is not giving
up he's touring the country telling his
supporters that he can still turn the
tide and win the upcoming election he
told the crowd he understood the message
voters sent him in the primary election
I know that these years especially the
last year has been very difficult I know
that you the middle class are the ones
who have made the greatest effort but I
want to tell you that I have listened I
have taken note and I have understood
but some analysts say the chances of
McCree winning the elections are slim my
feeling I don't really chill it's very
difficult to win an election when the
economy is as it is and the opposition
is united this year the GDP may fall
almost three percent which generates
recession and poverty so wrong that the
government is now desperately trying to
win back the support it has lost
terasawa al Jazeera when Osiris